[Musique]
quand on voit ces montagnes aux couleurs
d'automne on comprend pourquoi sotchi
est une destination de choix quelle que
soit la saison nous nous trouvons
actuellement dans une des télécabines
qui permettent d'accéder au complexe
touristique
les stations de ski compte plusieurs
téléphérique avec lesquels les touristes
peuvent parcourir une distance totale de
45 km et ainsi accéder au meilleur
panorama et point de départ de
randonnées ou de descente en ski ou en
snowboard située à deux heures et demie
à peine de la capitale russe sotchi
accueille chaque année en moyenne 6
millions de touristes russes et
étrangers attirés par sa proximité
immédiate avec la mer et les montagnes
malgré la pandémie de coronavirus et la
nouvelle règle en vigueur depuis le 1er
août dernier qui n'autorise l'accès aux
hôtels de la région qu'aux personnes
vaccinées ou s'engageant à le faire dans
les trois jours suivant leur arrivée le
nombre de visiteurs a été peu un papier
depuis le début de 2021 5,8 millions de
touristes ont déjà visité sotchi et les
autorités s'attendent en accueillir un
million supplémentaires d'ici la fin de
l'année je suppose toutes les
constructions toute l'infrastructure
sont très impressionnantes mais la chose
la plus impressionnante c'est la nature
vous aimeriez revenir en été
j'y reviendrai et plus d'une fois
j'aimerais bien y revenir chaque année
c'est un endroit formidable pour
retrouver de l'énergie interne pour
méditer l'endroit est vraiment
formidable
sotchi et bien sûr célèbre pour avoir
accueilli les jeux olympiques d'hiver
2014 est un des sites de la coupe du
monde 2018 c'est ici au bord de la mer
noire que se trouve le parc et le
village olympique
les préparatifs des jo ont permis à
sotchi de se moderniser et de développer
ses infrastructures qui sont encore
utilisé aujourd'hui pour l'organisation
de divers forums y compris le club de
discussion valdaï